por supuesto una noticia tan grande y
tan histórica obviamente llegó a este
Rincón del planeta por un lado
Obviamente el Primer Ministro israelí y
aís lapiz En nombre del gobierno y hacia
todos los ciudadanos británicos Y por
supuesto la familia real mostró sus
condolencias y dijo textualmente que la
reina Es una figura extraordinaria una
líder única que simbolizó la devoción y
el amor por su patria acto seguido el
presidente de israelí Isaac hershock
hizo lo propio dijo que la muerte de la
reina Isabel II es el fin de una era
vivió la historia hizo la historia y
dejó un legado en magnífico y en su caso
en el caso de las palabras de Isaac
jerson fueron mucho más emotivas que la
de yaíis Lápiz principalmente porque sus
padres a lo largo de los años tuvieron
diferentes audiencias con la Reina
Isabel básicamente las primeras fue como
porque su padre fue presidente también
del Estado israelí Jaime gerso entonces
recordó Cómo fue muy
hospitalaria utilizó esta palabra Y en
este sentido también obviamente como
decías otros líderes israelíes el propio
Mickey el presidente de la del
parlamento israelí a nuestras espaldas
que ahora no se ve porque está acá pero
él también reconoció que se convirtió en
las reinas Isabel II en una figura
política del mundo muy reconocida y por
ejemplo como un detalle simbólico en el
ayuntamiento de tel aviv en la ciudad de
tel aviv la alcaldía decidió proyectar
la bandera de la unión Jack en su
reconocimiento mientras que por el lado
palestino no hubo tantas no hubo tantos
mensajes en este sentido obviamente hubo
una condolencia pero mucho más concreta
que fue de la misión Palestina en Reino
Unido que dijo textualmente también que
la Reina Isabel fue un ancla en mares
tormentosos y modelo de decoro y orden
en un mundo turbulento
Yanira qué podemos decir acerca de esas
relaciones entre la Reina Isabel II que
tuvo con Israel
de alguna manera podemos decir que esas
relaciones así como decías no como
sabemos 70 años de reinado Pues fue algo
casi paralelo a la creación a la
independencia del estado de Israel este
ocurrió en 1948 su coronación de la
reina fue en 1952 y obviamente antes que
ella fuera monarca hay una relación
histórica con estas tierras en cuanto al
Reino Unido precisamente porque en esta
tierra Palestina histórica estuvo bajo
mandato británico y evidentemente hay
una relación desde ese entonces desde
mucho antes de su corazón pero bueno
mucho más concreto podemos decir que hay
una una gran cercanía de la reina con la
comunidad judía británica durante todo
su reinado eso es lo que lo que intentó
hacer con rabinos con personalidades con
esta comunidad civil en el país Pero
ha sido Aunque la relación con Israel el
estado de Israel ha sido diplomática
buena tranquila
no ha sido como por ejemplo países
vecinos como Jordania o Egipto porque
aunque no es algo oficial se habla de
una especie de embargo de parte de la
familia real para no visitar
oficialmente estas tierras de hecho la
Reina Isabel jamás vino oficialmente ni
extraoficialmente a este Rincón a
Jerusalén a Israel o territorios
palestinos actuales Pero bueno se cree
como decía que había una especie de
embargo que en 2015 un funcionario
británico le dijo a di telegraph que en
efecto hasta que no hubiese un pacto
entre el estado de Israel y la autoridad
nacional Palestina eso no ocurriría Y
obviamente por eso nunca se produjo aún
así en suelo británico ella siempre fue
hospitalaria y receptiva con las
personalidades distintas ya fueran
personalidades comunes o personalidades
mucho más altas Como por ejemplo a los
entonces presidentes
lo recibió mientras que a Simón Pérez en
2008 lo nombró caballero entonces como
presidente en su caso no Así que como
vemos esa relación ha sido mucho más
fuerte y como curiosa anécdota si
tenemos tiempo en 1994 el príncipe
Felipe de edimburgo su marido también
fallecido
vino a una especie de peregrinación aquí
en Jerusalén en memoria de su madre la
princesa Alicia de Grecia de la que está
enterrada en la que se sabe que está
enterrada en el Monte de Los Olivos aquí
en Jerusalén a escasos minutos